if China and the United States went
toe-to-toe is there a clear consensus as
to who would win that well I think it's
greatly contested it China goes 100 Full
Tilt invasion of Taiwan we do not have
enough Assets in the region to stop them
I think the Russians look at Ukraine as
the first step in a strategic war
against the United States the war really
needs to be stopped otherwise we try
really hard at Ford Observer not to be
like alarmists and hair on fire but Max
and I are both very concerned that the
use of a tactical nuclear weapon in
Ukraine to stop a Ukrainian offensive
that could become the first of several
first of many there are a lot of people
in institutions they look at the extreme
left and they say yeah that's not a
great look but they're useful you don't
come at this from one side is good the
other side is bad right someone how
we're talking about Russia Ukraine look
this shit's messy we are locked in a
spiral right now and so really the next
two years I think are going to be very
difficult all right guys bang bang I've
got Mike here with me I'm very excited
about this because you operate in a
world that I think most people don't
understand but is incredibly important
but it's all based on your background uh
you were an Intel in the military you
spent some time as a contractor walk us
through kind of what were you doing in
the military and then we can talk about
how you're Now using this in the
civilian world to keep people informed
well I I enlisted in 2004 I was a 96
Bravo Intel analyst and you know the the
military career I actually I didn't
really uh like it I guess but I loved
Beyond deployments you know you do your
job like you wake up you have a mission
you have stuff to do you know we always
say intelligence drives the fight and
I'm you know I'm not trying to you know
play this up right I mean most of the
time I was sitting at a computer but
people have to make decisions you know
commanders they and and teams they have
to go to x-place they have to know what
to expect once they get there and
somebody has to provide them with that
intelligence and so it really is a a
critical part of of War fighting and so
you know I I really did enjoy the
intelligence side you know you get to
you know experience things that
that not many other people do you get to
watch you know things on TV and say oh
that that's not right you know you know
that's the U.S spin on what actually
happened you know and so uh I tell you I
I really just I fell in love with the
job and um yeah and I then I got into
Contracting after that I did two
deployments I went to Afghanistan in
0607 Iraq 0809 and then uh as a contract
went back to Afghanistan for 2010 and
2011. and uh
you know I I I just I really in enjoyed
I really enjoyed that as a yeah well one
of the things uh as you're talking that
immediately goes back to is like you
wake up every day shave your face put on
the same uniform you know where to go
you know where to be you don't have to
make very many decisions and my life's
pretty easy and that's right people
who've never experienced it they're like
that sounds [ __ ] crazy these two guys
are idiots right yeah but like there is
this uh uh Clarity that comes from being
in an environment where uh you don't
really think for yourself sometimes
right now yeah out on the battlefield or
whatever
um or in in your case a lot of times
writing reports like you're having to
synthesize information uh but there is
something different about that
experience that I think it's hard for
people to understand until they go and
and do it when you were uh doing the
Intel work talk a little bit about the
training that you get before you
actually go out and get deployed and
things like that uh because I think most
people are like oh Intel like is that
like you know Jack Bauer is that like uh
uh some kind of field agent who's you
know hanging people up and like doing
all kinds of crazy stuff uh what is the
training like and then what does that
actually mean you know kind of day to
day when you're out uh in a deployment
yeah you know big army stuff big army
Intel is is like big army anything you
know um you know but there is a part of
the army that you know it's not James
Bond but you know it gets uh a little
bit into the gray gray zone or you know
gray area but yeah the train up you know
on the on the big army side it is
uh you you do your your train up it's
like you zero your rifle you go to the
range you get uh you know you qualify
with it with an M249 or you know
whatever you do rollover training you
know it's probably a lot like just for
everyone
um who's who's getting ready to deploy
and then but on the Intel side there is
you know how well do you know the area
as as soon as possible you know figure
out where you're going what unit you're
placing get in touch with them start
getting a lay of the land because
it's very important as especially as an
analyst you have to understand the
Baseline of where you're going so that
you can determine what is off Baseline
and so having a head start on where
you're going learning the local tribes
the local Power Players the Taliban
noxia Bondi whatever groups are active
in the area during that train up the
more you know about about those groups
and what they've been doing the better
off you'll be because you know once
you're once the unit you're replacing
rips out like there goes 11 or 12 months
worth of knowledge and it just literally
disappears and so you know and then all
sudden it's it's a commander asking you
you've been there for 30 days
expecting an answer like you've been
there for 12 months one of uh from my
experience uh some of this some
something that someone said to me early
on was they said the first two weeks in
the last two weeks is the most dangerous
ones and I was like why and they were
like look man you you think that these
people aren't paying attention you think
these people aren't uh actively thinking
all day long how do we kill these
[ __ ] right but like they are
sitting there all day long that's all
they're thinking about and when they see
that truck drive they're like I never
seen that truck with that number on it
before it's a new unit these dudes don't
know what they're doing yet they don't
know where they are they don't know who
we are like and it's sure enough like
the intensity of attacks in the
beginning and the end seemed kind of
crazy and you never really know why
right some of it's the changeover stuff
uh some of us maybe you're just on your
game you know kind of in the middle of
deployment uh but I remember also the
entire Intel that we would receive uh
there was a changing quality uh you know
right around uh when you would do kind
of Lefty right seat stuff and and it's
just fascinating now in hindsight kind
of a little bit older you get more
context you start understanding why this
stuff happens
but like that happened how many times
when units were changing out you know
throughout a 20-year war in two
different countries like thousands of
times right and so literally somebody
having to get up to speed on a brand new
area in a matter of days if not weeks
just happen over and over and over again
and you know Intel is just like any
other MOS like they're they're the guys
these guys are going to excel these guys
fairly average these guys should
probably be like you know refueling
trucks right and nothing against you
know the fuel guys because that's all
very important too you know I don't know
we could we can give them [ __ ] Yeah well
yeah no no it's just like you stick it
you know you stick in an 11 Bravo In The
Arms Room of course no because he
doesn't need to be out with with
everyone else so in Intel says it's the
exact same thing you know you have the
same same challenges as everybody else
just you know uh typically no nobody's
shooting at you so you talked about like
establish a Baseline and then recognize
when something's off Baseline um I'm
assuming that this is both in the
military and the Contracting work and
then what you're doing today kind of in
the civilian world and keeping people
informed on various threats and and kind
of regions of the world how do you tell
something's off base time like maybe
just when you go and you look at a
situation how do you establish a
Baseline and how do you know oh that's
that's an outlier that's something that
I should pay more attention to
well the first things you have to
establish a subject matter expertise on
your topic so you know I'm knowledgeable
about China and I can sit here and talk
a lot about China and Taiwan but I'm not
an expert in the Chinese military I'm
not a pla guy and so what you often kind
of see on social media you know
especially it's it's uh the Dunning
Kruger right you read the Wikipedia page
and you're you know here's my here's my
26 you know tweet thread on uh on the
Chinese pla you know so the first thing
in establishing a baseline is just have
to have vast amounts of knowledge and
information about what's going on
if you can there's a couple of ways you
can do this number one you can use an
indicator system where you know
we see uh
the the pla moving tanks around okay
well that's happened every day for the
past the past six months okay that
that's very in Baseline and then all of
a sudden there's double the number of
Tanks or in addition to tanks now it's
command and control vehicles or it's air
defense or uh you know something that
well we didn't see that last week now
we're seeing it now so identifying those
indicators is is kind of the the first
step there and
um
you know and then beyond that the
knowledge that you accrue just reading
through the news every day you know it's
I guess it's kind of the same thing you
say you know these these politicians or
these Chinese officials weren't talking
like this last last month now now they
are and what's caused that change yeah
um I know you're not an expert on China
but I think everyone who hears China now
wants to know are they going to take
Taiwan when why how how do you all just
kind of wrap your heads around uh a
geopolitical situation that not only is
rooted in the current day uh in kind of
what I would consider more military
Warfare and strategy and things like
that there's also a commercial uh kind
of threat standpoint obviously with the
uh the chips and kind of uh Taiwan uh uh
Taiwan being so important to kind of the
global infrastructure uh in that regard
but there's also a historical component
to this you know how did Taiwan get to
the point where it is today and what is
kind of the expectation over time like
how do you all break down a situation
like that
well first yes subject matter expertise
and you you look at you never as an
analyst you never want to say well China
is going to do X and they're going to do
it on on X day
being an analyst on stuff something like
this is one reason why it's very
difficult is because they may not have
decided exactly what they're going to do
yet
and so you're being asked hey what is
China going to do how are they going to
do this and if they haven't decided Well
it's it's an impossible task yeah
however you know you look at
at what China has said in the past and
China said well we don't want to fight a
war I think that's true I don't think
they want to fight a conventional War
because it's not just going to be
against the United States it's going to
be against Australia or Japan and other
countries are probably going to get
involved at that point and really at
that point we're looking at World War
III anyway they want to avoid that
unless they're maybe 100 sure
that they can win I don't think they're
there so we have
uh this thing called The Gray Zone and
it exists under below the threshold of
conventional War
and so you know this is like using uh
China's doing this a lot with their the
maritime militia they have a bunch of
fishing boats that are armed and they
act as like a quasi you know they call
the maritime militia quasi-chinese pla
Navy but but they're just out there
trawling you know trying to catch
fishing so I uh you know my our trying
to analyst Max has talked about this
quite a bit we really think China's
China does well in the gray Zone they
really excel in the gray zone so
probably the most most likely course of
action at this point it doesn't mean
it's a hundred percent but most likely
course of action is stay in the gray
zone why risk fighting a conventional
War when you can just surround Taiwan
and embargo it and you're not dropping
bombs on Taiwan you know you're not
threatening to Nuke Taipei but you're
also being highly coercive you're just
you have not triggered War yet
and so if there's a you know some sort
of embargo blockade whatever kind of the
various tactics are uh the idea would be
that you uh almost have implicit control
uh you were driving the situation you're
coercing uh kind of what plays out but
you yet haven't stepped over the line to
a point where uh the United States or
other countries may say hey that's an
act of war and now we're going to come
you know toe-to-toe with you uh
and so by doing that that's kind of this
gray Zone you're talking about where uh
you have immense impact on the situation
but you're very careful as to where the
line is you never kind of step over is
that like a fair way to kind of think
about it yeah absolutely
um you know it's like uh using
you know like let's just look at maybe a
domestic scenario right okay I shoot you
with the paintball right is that going
to cause you to use your firearm against
me uh maybe not this legal gray area
you're probably going to prison you know
that's kind of a gray Zone tactic you
know it's where you are still taking
steps to achieve your will you're
disrupting the enemy you're deterring
you know their their vast military might
in terms of the United States just the
massive amount of Firepower that could
be over there yeah you're still carrying
out your objectives you're just not
triggering war you're you're not causing
the other guy to pull the trigger yet
if China and the United States went
toe-to-toe uh I understand I actually
agree with you that it's unlikely uh
that either country wants that now
whether it happens we'll we'll see but
uh if we got to that point is there a
clear uh consensus whether it's in the
Intel Community uh or just kind of in
private conversations as to who would
win that
well I think it's greatly contested so a
lot of it depends on
one thing our our trying to analyst Max
talks about is the tyranny of distance
we do not have enough Assets in there if
China goes 100 Full Tilt high intensity
conventional War invasion of Taiwan we
do not have enough Assets in the region
to stop them
and so this is a case where China over
the course of several days can
be uh can start their an amphibious
assault against Taiwan so a uh it's
going to be very difficult for the
United States to to win that war just
because it's going to take us so long to
get over there how how long is this like
a two week period or is this like two
two three months like easy four to six
weeks to get well okay so we have I mean
we have a couple of uh
uh carrier strike groups in the region
but and I'm not a Navy guy but I would
you know I'd expect easy four to six
weeks to start start putting stuff over
there you know we've been doing a lot of
uh kind of uh pre-positioned stock
programs over there uh we rebase some uh
bombers to Australia we're striking up
some deal with the Philippines I imagine
we're gonna start storing Munitions over
there but I you know I forgot who said
this but I I think it's the uh some Air
Force General over there uh in Endo
indo-pacific command he said they have
something like 10 days worth of
Munitions in in a full-on fight against
China they have 10 days worth of
munition so we better win it in 10 days
that's why that's why I have very
significant doubt that we can actually
win that war short of full-scale
mobilization put everybody in theater
and throw everything you have at the
Chinese what I find
um intellectually interesting about kind
of the the war gaming of this the the
kind of hypothetical situations
um you know and
people probably talk about this before
but like it's not to minimize uh the
obvious loss of life and kind of all the
seriousness of War
um but this is not an exercise of uh
where the United States has been highly
successful recently this is not hey call
CL Team Six and let's set a couple guys
over and like do their thing and they
come back we talk about it on National
Television like we win right this is
very much uh if there is a uh direct
combat type engagement uh the United
States is gonna have to bring Jets bombs
Strikers you know I mean just everything
we got and
um we haven't fought a war like that in
a long time and what I think ends up
being interesting is it's also not on
land right now yes could we get it to
land could we kind of go play that game
of course uh but what we're talking
about here talking about you know a
maritime militia I was talking about
Navy we're talking about all these
different things that add a degree of
complexity which it is unclear to me as
a civilian who doesn't spend all day
thinking about the stuff and reading it
uh how good are we right in in that uh
environment so how do you think about
like forget what China would do just
like the United States Readiness and its
ability to uh if it had everything in
place just fight in the sea against you
know any enemy
so the first thing I think about uh
about a war over there is logistics you
know we got to get troops over there we
got to get equipment we're gonna get
spare parts food water ammo all that
stuff uh China does not have a highly
capable Blue Water Navy they're trying
to I mean they're in the process of
developing that so uh you know the first
thing is how
uh how difficult will it be for us to
have like an Iraq style Logistics train
but to the indo-pacific now some of that
stuff will be coming from our allies in
the region
we gotta go back to like 10 days worth
of Munitions you know how how many weeks
is it going to take for us to get more
stuff over there and you know the thing
is it's not just getting more stuff over
there we've been supplying Ukraine with
so many Munitions now and I can't
confirm that this is true but you know
I'm sure people have seen it around like
we have Army units right now and Marine
units saying hey we're running out of
high marks we don't even have high marks
to train the new guys who are just
getting it to their first station and so
you know I I really do question is this
this is probably going to take like
years for us to replenish all the
Munitions that we've already sent to
Ukraine so that's the second thing I
think about I I do Wonder
um again it's very easy to talk about
Russia Ukraine as uh a conflict and uh
contained conflict in the sense of you
know two countries are going at it
um and the United States obviously has a
vested interest in uh
um trying to uh participate there's
plenty of people who think that we
shouldn't be participating in any form
or fashion but uh uh we're at least
sending Aid at the moment there was
confirmation recently uh that there are
troops on the ground what they're doing
highly controversial debatable the whole
thing
um but it sounds like so far there has
been no confirmation that U.S troops are
actually engaged in direct Combat on the
ground with you know Russian troops or
whatever uh with that said it's very
easy to talk about China and Taiwan and
the direct conflict there in a
self-contained kind of environment but
what you're really highlighting is like
no man it's a global game all right and
you know imagine the world where uh
Russia and Ukraine is just the warm-up
to China Taiwan and to your point we've
depleted resources we've depleted the
will of the American citizens of our
politicians of military leadership uh to
engage now in a dual front you know
battle where uh on the outside of either
one of those you would say it is really
important you put them both together
it's like [ __ ] this gets kind of crazy
and so
um
do you think that this is top of mind
for people right now like the political
leaders the folks who who uh kind of
read the Intel that you guys put out on
a daily basis or is this something that
you all are sitting there looking at it
more from like a military strategy
standpoint you're like yeah I'm sure the
military leaders are thinking about it
but everyone else pretty much is you
know not even aware or thinking that
this is an important uh kind of
component to consider
well from the Eastern perspective the
Russian and Chinese perspective I I
think the Russians look at Ukraine as
the first step in a strategic war
against the United States
China looks at Taiwan probably as you
know if they lose
then this may be the end of the the
quote-unquote Chinese Century but for
the Chinese they look at this and they
say this is a stepping stone to
replacing U.S Global Gemini and they're
right now doing this economically and
trying to do it financially I don't
think they want to do it militarily but
they're one way or the other they're
going to take Taiwan or they're going to
lose a billion people trying to do it so
from the Eastern respect Eastern
perspective yeah this is about the next
Century this is which sphere is going to
own you know kind of have Global
dominance for the United States you read
the latest National Security strategy
and latest National defense strategy and
they're well aware I mean they outline
it they say this decade is going to be
decisive it is going to determine what
happens this decade is going to
determine the new rules-based
international order I think they're
acutely aware of it I had I I think
they're way behind the curve though
when you think about
um the military conflict it's easy to
say hey I get it cool we don't line up
you know soldiers in a line in a field
anymore and kind of fire uh but the
direct combat I think people can wrap
their heads around you mentioned
financial and economic war and kind of
uh again this uh ability to uh
drastically kind of influence the
direction of things without actually
stepping over that line what do you all
pay the most attention to or most
worried about in terms of the other
types of uh maybe in a in the most uh
easy way to describe it competition uh
in the most kind of uh direct and
abrasive way the actual conflict that is
happening uh you know that isn't
military but it's more economic
yeah I think competition is uh
is a diplomatic term it's I think the
United States and China and the east in
general I think they are uh going to be
locked in into kind of in an economic
and financial death match when Biden
signed the chips act and we undercut
Chinese Chips production and that's
that's escalatory that's very
significant and we're still looking at
how is trying to go into retali I don't
think you know she just can't Chinese
president Xi Jinping came out uh some
time ago and apparently wrote a letter
to some Chinese interest groups in the
United States saying we don't want a
confrontation we don't want to escalate
and that's what they say but uh you know
back in Beijing that's not at all what
they're doing Chinese foreign minister
Wang Yi has even come out on numerous
times this year and said Asia's time in
global governance has come like we are
going to replace the United States we're
going to topple the unipolar world we're
going to cement China as a driver of of
and as a matter of fact they have this
thing called the global development
initiative or the Global Security
initiative we see China establishing
bricks and the brics plus which is
fairly new you know our Argentina Saudi
Arabia several other countries actually
I think we're up to 19 countries now
that have said that they plan to apply
or very interested in joining brics plus
and so economically I guess this should
say monetarily China does not want to I
don't think they want to replace the US
dollar as the world Reserve I don't
think why not
uh because their Capital markets and
credit markets are not large enough to
do it the no one uh no one in Brazil
wants to accept the Yuan right now or
remnb but what they can do is is use is
use bricks and Bricks plus to undermine
the US dollar for probably 20 to 40
percent of global trade and I think uh I
think the Chinese would be very happy to
do that because if Brazil and uh India
are no longer using the dollar as the
standard of Trades and uh I mean that
greatly diminishes U.S power and
influence abroad
and so yeah I think China's not in a
position to do that and uh undermining
the dollar is is Gray Zone Warfare I
mean it is monetary and economic Warfare
they're going to cause potentially cause
a massive monetary crisis if if they do
start going down this road and more and
more countries start saying yeah we're
not going to use the dollar we'll do
bilateral currency trade we'll just if
we have a a trade if our trade is even
then we're basically we're just swapping
each other's currencies and as long as
those currencies remain stable we don't
have to use the dollar well that's a lot
of international Demand Being just
disappearing that's exactly what the
Chinese want
uh when you talk about currencies
obviously everybody who watches this
says oh bitcoin's the solution right
um and uh and I'll kind of give some
context here one of the ideas that I've
had which I don't necessarily uh think
is uh is right or see a clear path as to
why it's wrong but I think it's
interesting
um I've always thought that uh the
single best place to be is to be the
owner of the global Reserve currency
right as we've seen for you know
centuries now uh but if you are not the
owner of the global Reserve currency the
second best place to be is to be using a
currency along with everyone else that
no one controls right and so kind of
this idea of okay I want the global
Reserve currency if I can't have it then
no one should have it and then we should
go use something that's decentralized or
whatever uh
I like Bitcoin right on I got a ton of
bias when it comes to that that story
sounds awesome uh how do you see Bitcoin
cryptocurrency stable coins like all
these different technologies that are
kind of related uh um in some form or
fashion kind of coming from one industry
playing into these geopolitical uh games
especially like economic and monetary
Warfare where okay if we can take away
US dollar demand like that helps us push
forward this kind of 100 year plan that
we have
I do watch the Federal Reserve with
great interest interest where it can't
uh concerns Central Bank digital
currencies I know they like it's every
week their their fed Bank presidents are
coming out saying hey we have to have
more regulation we've got to have
congressional action I think they
understand that stable coins are going
to play a much larger role in in the U.S
and international economies and this is
not an area where they can lose control
I mean you just if you're the fed you
cannot lose a monopoly over the US
dollar or the use of of TR of dollar
denominated trade
I you know I don't know
I know there's a lot of a lot of stable
like very serious stable currencies and
the people developing those are
developing our stable coins sorry
developing those to replace the US
dollar and I'll tell you I'm just not
sure how the FED is going to be able to
to co-opt that I'm not I'm not an fx guy
I'm not a big uh monetary uh
academic but I you know I do wonder if
if those stable coins are backed one to
one to the dollar
maybe that alone is good for the FED
because it just creates additional
demand even though Tron is trying to
actively sap demand for the dollar in
international trade yeah it's um uh it's
something I've paid attention to for
five years now um I can remember 2018
2019 literally going on National
Television talking about this idea of
hey uh if the United States wants to
remain uh the leader and have the gold
Reserve currency uh there are a ton of
risks and a ton of reasons why I
actually don't think central bank
digital currencies are good one of the
pro arguments would be that it's all
about accessibility and so if you're in
Venezuela and your local currency fails
uh and you say well [ __ ] that's not good
so I want dollars I can't get dollars
because it's dangerous it's difficult it
costs a lot you know what whatever the
reason is
um and if I try to flee something that's
physical like gold or whatever that's
also dangerous uh let me get on the
internet what can I use there it's
actually not in many cases Bitcoin right
it's volatile they don't understand it
there's always three things they can get
access to a digital dollar to your point
it's back one to one of the dollar
that's damn well it's just as good as
having a dollar right in that scenario
right but if there is no digital dollar
that's super popular especially one that
is uh backed by and uh kind of put into
the market by the Federal Reserve but
there so happens to be a Chinese
currency
well [ __ ] I may become a fan of that
because it provides me stability and the
ability to use an additional environment
and kind of all these things and so I've
always thought that uh the digital
currencies especially the Central Bank
digital currencies uh yeah there's you
know who's faster who you know is
cheaper to use a lot of stuff but
there's just a pure accessibility play
uh and kind of competition because
ultimately there are people around the
world where their currency fails them
and they're looking for an alternative
and some of them will turn to bitcoin
and you know decentralized or private
currencies or whatever uh some of them
are going to turn to Central Bank
digital currencies uh and kind of
whoever has got the most you know kind
of uh or the furthest so far whoever's
got the most accessibility has a
significant advantage in my opinion
you know I I look at this as another
Avenue for Gray Zone Warfare
you know I I think probably the FED
right now is intentionally trying to
crush all other competitor currencies
you know like like the Yuan rimminbi and
uh
it's been pretty damn successful at that
they have been they absolutely have been
and so you know if you're if you're
trying to obviously do not like this I
am quite concerned about how China is
going to retaliate you know China
they're not doing well I mean they're
really kind of on the ropes economically
this you know this thing like oh we're
gonna be happy with five percent you
know GDP growth okay you know whatever
you have to tell Financial Times you
know to but you know they've had massive
investor outflows a lot of money leaving
that country a lot of concern about how
uh about Western sanctions how you know
if China is going to get the Russia
treatment over Taiwan and so I I don't
know how successful China is actually
going to be when when they're making
and China's in a position where they
have to grow the bricks plus because a
lot of these other current countries are
going to start turning on on Chinese
Commerce and the more the world
bifurcates and you know Peter Zeon talks
about uh de-globalization uh that's a
real threat to China and so I I look at
that and uh just what's I think what's
going to end up happening is you know
we're going to go right back we're
already probably already are right back
into the cold cold war and uh and these
fears are probably going to be attacking
each other's currencies just because
they can get away with it and know
that's that's not going to trigger world
war three yeah uh Vladimir Putin uh
President of Russia has been uh quite
Lucid in uh in his commentary about uh
the U.S economy
um about the uh U.S addiction the social
media and printing money I mean just
there's line after line after line in
many of his recent speeches where you
listen to it you say listen I get it
people are super pissed and rightfully
so that he invaded Ukraine and kind of
all these things that that they're quite
upset about
um but if you can separate out the man
from the comment ends comments seem like
something we should be paying attention
to and it fits very similarly in line
with I think what you're talking about
from China's perspective
um obviously I don't see a lot of people
lining up to go get the ruble right
right um and there hadn't been nearly as
much investment in that country as there
had been in China and kind of they're
coming out from a different perspective
um
but he talks about a multi-polar world
and that's like the the phrase he
continuously uses over and over and over
again
is that ultimately the goal it's not
actually even to crush the United States
have the United States suffered some you
know immense way it's like hey look if
we can just pull ourselves up to be
equivalent to the United States they've
got kind of one you know side of the
world we got the other side and and that
alone would be Victory is that kind of
the way you look at it or is that maybe
uh uh being too innocent naive in terms
of their intentions and what they also
might think is possible
it's probably a first step
but there are there are other steps I
really do I think Putin wants to see the
United States suffer he looks at the
fall the collapse of the Soviet Union as
a humiliating event and you know this is
something he says in his speeches one of
the LA you know he gave a speech last
month and he said you know the real
travesty of the last century is that
when the when the Soviet Union fell
there was no counterweight there was no
counterbalance to world power and he has
to provide that balance I think Ukraine
is a first step towards that we see
Russia and China expanding and deepening
their Alliance that is part of of that I
I don't think I don't think China is
going to be happy with just a
multi-polar world their uh their
resource starved they've got a billion
people they need
components and materials they really
don't I mean there's no virtually no
domestic I mean there's some oil but not
a lot uh their net importer of of food
and fuel and so I don't think this is
simply I don't think the United States
is going to be happy with that outcome
and I don't think China or Russia are
going to be happy with outcome so I
think we're probably in a position where
one side wins out right over the other
it's a peric victory and we just both
destroy each other
or maybe you know I'd say maybe some
some third party that's relatively
unscathed kind of becomes the next
Global superpower
so but to answer the question I I don't
see China being happy with that
definitely not Russia
Putin's invasion of Ukraine
um how do you evaluate it obviously uh
it's been condemned by pretty much every
country in the West for the most part
um they uh don't buy the story of the
denotification of Ukraine
um they obviously uh believe there's a
threat for uh nuclear war
um and I think it's pretty well covered
and kind of documented in terms of both
uh the Western point of view of the
action the actual Invasion itself uh a
little bit of a celebration in that they
weren't necessarily able to overrun the
country and maybe the way that uh the
West would like to think that they
thought they could do
and now you got kind of a western force
that continues to supply Aid and
weaponry and kind of all the stuff
locked up uh you know with the uh
country of Russia
how do you look at it like like what are
the main takeaways for people and then
are there things that maybe that the
West has been told or uh the media has
covered that might not either be true or
maybe we shouldn't put as much weight on
as they already have
I think the West did
overestimate Russian capabilities or a
guy went to college with is still in the
Army and you know he's he was telling me
about how they're running all these
drills to uh
to learn how to deal with Russian
Artillery on the on the battlefield and
you know at that time this is a few
years ago Russian Artillery outranged
what we had and so I do think there was
and a few other guys led me to believe
that you know there was the expectation
that Russia was the bear was back you
know so to speak uh I think the Russians
have probably underperformed their
expectations in Ukraine when when Putin
came out and and fired a bunch of
generals
um that's a pretty sure sign that they
were not doing well or they're they're
not doing uh meeting this meeting his
standard and I think that's probably the
biggest indicator that that Putin has
been disappointed in in Ukraine so you
think that the United States we
overestimated what they were capable of
doing which I guess if you missed like
that's probably the better direction to
miss in uh and at the same time they
were overestimating their capabilities
Uh Russian forces are underperforming
Putin's expectations and kind of desires
and so you get kind of this I don't want
to call it a stalemates it feels like
they're they're still uh pretty heavy
direct fighting
um but it does feel like it's now gone
from like defend Ukraine to like there
is war and you know I I don't know the
future but it almost feels like hey if
you woke up 10 years from now and they
were still fighting each other Iraq
Afghanistan right like kind of just hey
they're just locked into this kind of
drawn out ore now uh that doesn't seem
to have an end because they don't they
won't come to the table with each other
there's a lot of people who believe they
shouldn't come to the table with each
other and so how do you kind of say okay
where are we now and like where is this
going
well it's going nowhere good
and you know you saw last month that the
Democratic Progressive or Progressive
Democratic caucus come out and they they
accidentally sent that letter to Biden
and said hey go talk to the Russians you
know stop the War uh yeah the war has to
be stopped I think we are getting close
much closer to the nuclear threshold and
when zelinski and the ukrainians say oh
we're going to go into Crimea we're
going to go and we're going to retake
dumbass uh that is right into that
Russian Doctrine says hey there's like
three reasons three cases where we would
use uh nuclear weapons and a
a violation of you of Russian
territorial Integrity is one of them and
so this probably is the case where if if
the ukrainians do pose a significant
threat to Crimea and uh then yeah I
think I mean China would be well within
their Doctrine to use new nuclear
weapons so I think actually this is the
case where like the war really needs to
be stopped otherwise
I we try really hard at forward Observer
not to be like alarmists and hair on
fire but Max and I are both very
concerned that the use of a tactical
nuclear weapon in Ukraine to stop a a
Ukrainian offensive uh could could well
I mean that that could become the first
of several first of many okay so uh
there's a lot of people who um there's
some details in here that I don't think
that they're quite aware of
um Crimea and Don bass I think is an
interesting area I'm not an expert I
don't know if you consider yourself an
expert or maybe I seen it on the map
okay all right you see another map uh
Russia took it and uh from their view my
understanding is they believe that that
is Russian territory that was outside of
the Russian borders and now they took it
back it's theirs case closed and they
don't really want to talk about anything
else other than that's ours uh Ukraine
feels like hey you invaded Crimea and
then Don bass and you stole that from us
and uh you know we may not come back
right away but we're gonna get our
[ __ ] country back right we're gonna
get our land back
um Russia invades Ukraine uh and the
Ukrainian is part of the surprise I
think to many people in the west and
frankly even ukrainians that I know
people in Eastern Europe right that I've
talked to are like damn the ukrainians
have held their own right they've been
able to put up a fight in a way that
whether it's the Russians screwing up or
the ukrainians just you know
outperforming expectations uh they have
been able to hold Russians off
but what you just described as not
defensive now what the conversation has
shifted to and zelinski has publicly
said I think on multiple occasions uh is
that the ukrainians believe that once
they basically push back the Russians
they then will go past what has been the
critical board and I put that in air
quotes because debated
um of Russia and Ukraine and they are
going to take back Crimea uh Crimea and
dondas now
a lot of people in this entire region
been fighting each other for a long time
right and uh I don't think it's fair uh
and frankly it'd be arrogant ignorant I
think for Americans to sit here and say
we know exactly who's what and where
they is and who owns what and the whole
thing there's a lot of [ __ ] that we will
never understand frankly because I don't
speak Russian right and then so like you
just get through all the complexity all
the caveats
but your point is that if Ukraine does
breach that line and say hey we are
coming for Crimea we are coming for Don
bass and we are going to take them and
the Russians believe that it is possible
that's where you think that the nuclear
weapon could be used
yes
but it's not a prediction but I will
just say yeah you think it's pressure
would be would be well within their
doctrine of of use okay now yeah Crimea
has been a part of Russia uh since I
mean since the American Revolution and
yeah you're absolutely right we really
do a a disservice to this conflict by
trying to view everything through
American lenses it's not it is rarely
the case where things are just as cut
and dry as good guy and bad guy hey you
know what if they're both bad guys I
mean let's just be honest here you know
I especially or to that point
War happens and in war there's a lot of
nasty [ __ ] that happens sure right on
both sides yeah and so to uh uh from my
view to slap our moral Frameworks onto
this uh is to essentially raise our
hands and say we don't understand War
right to some degree yeah yeah
absolutely yeah war is more than just
the application of violence especially
among the people involved I mean there's
a lot of psychology and information
operations you know involve the mental
the mental space so yeah I think you
know
um Putin has talked about doing this I
mean done uh you know Donetsk way back
in the you know mid mid 2010s
um Donetsk and Lou Hans there are ethnic
Russians in that part of the country and
I'm not going to sit here and say that
their elections and referendums were
free and fair and they said oh yeah hey
let's go join the Russian Federation
undoubtedly a lot of them want want that
exactly but I think this is a case where
you know where Putin says look they're
ethnic Russians there and we are going
to go back and reclaim territory from
the Russian Federation that should have
never been given to Ukraine never given
away and so you know that's that's where
they are I'm a realist and I say is
there there's not a perfect world you
you really cannot have your cake and eat
it too the best thing that could
possibly happen I think for the world is
is for Crimea and and uh the Dom bass
regions to be in the Russian Federation
and in in the war because otherwise
zelinski look zielinski wants this thing
to go nuclear he wants NATO to get
involved zelinski will start World War
III to save Ukraine
and I'm just
uh I'm not in that position to support
that so it's very interesting because uh
zielinski
um I remember reading I don't know
whenever he got elected a couple years
ago uh I believe Trump got elected and
then zelinski had elected shortly
thereafter you know a year or two
whatever
um I just read a headline comedian gets
elected right right and I was like oh
like got a TV star right then we got a
comedian like is this gonna be a thing
and that was basically my only exposure
whatsoever to a teslinski
um and then when the war started I saw
him on television I said damn that guy
seems pretty inspirational you could see
how a country would rally around this
individual right and a friend said to me
go don't forget he's an actor right and
and so uh by the way so are many
politicians in the United States whether
they get paid for it or not right they
put on the face and then they go and
then they're Media train they've got
great communication skills like all the
things that you need to be a politician
and be successful
um
and then it started to get kind of crazy
in my opinion because you had uh the
Russians doing things that you'd wake up
every morning you'd be like that's crazy
right and like that's bad and then you
would hear language from American
politicians from zelinski and other
people around the world like this isn't
just you know Russia Ukraine and the
United States this is NATO this is other
countries whatever
and he just started saying like holy
[ __ ] does anybody actually want it to
end right and I think your point about
like
if zelinski and again it's if right if
zelinski's strategy is to basically keep
ratcheting this up until NATO steps in
and says we will protect you we promise
you uh we have your back
I mean it seems pretty clear that Russia
would then say [ __ ] send the nukes
right and at that point if NATO is
involved like that just doesn't seem
like a good place I I don't know I'm
very confused in terms of like how the
war game plays out if we get to a point
where Solinski is super offensive and
the Russians actually use a nuke kind of
what happens after that
yeah that's a good question I think the
U.S defense establishment
I think a lot of them do want to get
more involved I would bet dollars of
donuts that NATO has troops in Ukraine I
mean there are soft dudes out there you
know whacking Russians for sure uh you
know there's some of them who don't even
have Uniforms on them I see them on
Instagram right yeah yeah that's right
those are the unsanct ones yeah
they're in like Ukrainian uniforms I
should yeah be more clear uh but so I
you know if if you're Poland if you're
the baltics
um you you probably don't want the war
to end you you want to see it keep going
in Western sanctions try to bleed Russia
dry
Putin came out I think in like September
or maybe October came out and said yeah
the Russian economy has we're going to
have challenges we have to actually
pivot the economy away from oil and gas
and he said we have to start developing
new Industries and so you know I I think
Putin understands this is going to be
like a long-term strategic battle if
you're if you're Poland in the baltics
you don't want to be next I mean if
you're Lithuania and Estonia have
ethnically Russian populations in the
Eastern parts of those countries they
don't want to be dumbass I completely
completely understand that and so from
there from NATO's perspective you say
well if you if you if you give Russia
this cookie they're going to try to take
the whole cake and uh you know which I I
think there's probably some truth to the
argument so this is a very complex issue
it's not just like hey
um you know Russia bad NATO good
honestly yeah so I I don't even think
NATO's a good guy anymore but you don't
think NATO is a good guy anymore
NATO NATO
uh all these NATO leaders they're
they're all globalists and you know you
look at a lot of these European leaders
they're all all weft people world
economic Forum the superstars or the
young weifers or whatever they're called
you know and I you know I'm I'm an
anti-globalist I don't I don't want to
see that and by supporting NATO that's
exactly what you're supporting now
and I you know just personally I try not
to interject my my personal beliefs into
this but
um yeah I don't think NATO's the good
guy anymore I think NATO is is defending
and advancing globalism in
when they do that I think their argument
would be and uh I always try to think
kind of like what's the pro and con
argument right they're already maybe
like well we were we were lured into it
right we were somebody else instigated
and we're just kind of finishing the
fight
um do you think that has weight or or
kind of holds water or do you think that
uh that sounds good and you know as a
sound bite but uh may not be as as uh
as obvious maybe when you actually do
the analysis
NATO exists as a defender of Mo
rules-based International order and
so you know native they can say yeah
we're
yeah we were uh I don't think they could
say like we're we're lured into
supporting Ukraine
but
you didn't you didn't ask this question
but I'll just tack on you know we've
seen South Korea and Japan get involved
in in NATO NATO they've been sending
officials to Japan and NATO working on
Military interoperability the this NATO
Summit in June they came out and said
hey we're going to start taking an
increased focus in the indo-pacific
theater because China is a direct threat
now to Nato or something like that China
is a competitor or something like that
and this is global NATO I I just ask if
NATO is not going to stick to the North
Atlantic and now they're going to shift
into Global NATO like what's step three
and I don't I you know I don't um I
don't I don't want to get close to step
three yeah yeah
um the last thing I want to talk about
uh Russia Ukraine uh nuclear
weapons of any degree I think scare the
[ __ ] out of people right uh uh some
cases rightfully so and some of it's
just ignorance they don't understand
um
I'm kind of the first part is like
tactically
did I just shoot one right do they uh is
it like uh hey let's cover the whole
country like how do you think
um uh do they actually go just after
Crimea in the donbass region like like
I guess if you had to say like okay cool
we get to the point where they're like
yes this is the line you breached the
line we are going to use these weapons
what does that look like from a tactical
standpoint
well conventional deployment yeah they
they could put on a rocket or you know
or a plane drop a bomb or something like
that I think a very Russian thing to do
and by the way the ukrainians and
Russians have been both accusing each
other of getting ready to deploy a dirty
bomb and so a very Russian thing to do
would be to deploy a dirty bomb and
blame it on the ukrainians explain what
a dirty bomb is oh just a radiological
device where you know it's not actually
a nuclear weapon but it's an ex it's an
explosive with uh with nuclear chemicals
in there and you just and you get all
the radiological elements dispersed and
it's not like a big atomic bomb but like
it kills people it not only kills people
that area has to be uninhabited you
cannot live there anymore and I think
the strategy would be deploy one and say
all right yeah Ukraine you wanna you
wanna keep talking you want to keep
coming into Crimea telling us how you're
going to come into Crimea that's fine
we'll set another one off so I would
hope it's I hope it's zero but after
that I hope it's it's one and done but
this is how you know this is kind of a
it's very escalatory but this is this
may be how Russia tries to break Ukraine
um
when that occurs what do you think the
response is like the Tactical component
of sure they could drop a bomb or rocket
whatever I think actually if I ask the
average person on the street in America
they'd say that's how it's going to
happen right like they're going to shoot
a rocket over and and we've got some
defense or we're going to do something
or whatever I have no clue uh but let's
say that there is some escalatory uh uh
kind of dirty bomb nuclear weapon
whatever used by Russia what is the
reaction from nato in the U.S is that
[ __ ] game on we're bringing every you
know all hell and Fury with us and like
we're gonna just take down uh uh Putin
and Russia and just not even in the Don
bass Crimea region but like now we're
coming after the whole country or do you
think it's more measured than that
maybe it depends on delivery you know I
said rocket but they could put on like a
short-range ballistic missile or
something like that
that's the same thing to the people on
the street so
um
the uh you know you have like General
Petraeus come out and say we're going to
wipe the Russians out out of Ukraine
we're going to hit every single Russian
military facility in Ukraine if Russia
does go nuclear
and I don't know if Petraeus is is the
talking head for for the White House
or if he's or if that's more like you
know his opinion and kind of bravado
um I I don't know that the not I don't
know that the U.S military frankly
um other than maybe an aerial campaign
uh I just you know honestly I keep going
back to the nuclear thing if you know
they wanted us to start this uh this
no-fly zone over Ukraine which by the
way I still think is potentially an
option here that may be one U.S or
potential course of action is to
establish a no-fly zone and say well if
it's violated then you're gonna have to
literally fight everybody now
so it probably depends on on delivery
and maybe where it is too I mean if it's
in like some industrial facility maybe
you know I mean that's bad it's not as
bad as setting one off in downtown Kiev
yeah so maybe it depends I I don't have
any insight into you know what the the
four stars at the Pentagon are thinking
but
my bet would be the the worse the
scenario probably the higher the greater
the U.S response would be yeah one of
the things that um
fascinates me after having you know been
in a war zone is uh there's the war you
see and then there's the war that you
don't see and the war that you don't see
um uh and I've talked about it before
with other guests uh in some ways almost
crazier right uh and people would expect
it to be okay there's a lot of stuff
that's happening you know uh in the
cover of dark or the tactics or whatever
but this specific scenario to me seems
the perfect setup because you do have
some pretty immense threats the US is uh
I guess I'm a technicality not involved
uh but it's I'd be shocked if we weren't
very well aware of as much as possible
um and uh in a position to step in if
needed and so uh if that is the case my
guess is that the Russians know that and
the ukrainians know that uh and so does
NATO and and you get into this almost
like there's a uh uh kind of in front of
the curtain behind the curtain and
what's going on behind the curtain
um feels more like chess and what's
going on in front of the curtain feels
more like Checkers of just like you know
hey okay I move here what are you gonna
do right and and at the same time people
are behind the curtain and you know uh
they're waiting to see what the what
everyone else in the chess board does
before they go ahead and they make their
decisions yeah this is bigger than
Ukraine I mean for Putin Ukraine is
probably a first step and for the United
States I think honestly I just I think
they want a regime change Putin and so
if if the United States the West is
successful in defeating the Russians in
Ukraine and uh turning turning just be
turning Crimea and Don bass back into
kind of disputed territory like 2017.
um I think they'll go after Putin
what does that look like and that's the
CH I mean that's the chess uh you know
they try to do it through sanctions
going after the oligarchs and getting
the oligarchs to turn on Putin it didn't
work uh I'm actually shocked as to how
little it seems to have impacted a whole
bunch of things but it's like
you see the sanctions they're pissed
right obviously uh they're trying to
distance themselves I mean you know all
the things you would expect from like an
individual incentive mechanism
but unless you guys have some
information or done some work that I'm
unaware of it doesn't seem like it
really had that much of an impact uh
within the country of Russia maybe there
was some Uprising but but nothing that
really seems material
I think when you're in a position where
you you lose your yacht or you lose your
life
things get a lot simpler decision wise
and so
um yeah I
yeah you you do you look at the
individual oligarchs who were sanctioned
and yeah they lost a lot of money
um I I don't I don't see how they can
think like maybe they'll ever get that
back and so
um I I also I don't know you know we
what I mean we'd have to sit down and
kind of you know think think this
through but there are undoubtedly ways
in which the United States and the West
could turn the heat up on on Putin
um as for how how they regime change
them I don't know I I really honestly
well let me say this
I'm not going to answer that right now
and not because I haven't don't have
inside information but I tell you I
really want to give you like well
thought out answers and I clearly have
not thought this through but there are
ways yeah when
um when we think about the United States
fight abroad What's um what's
fascinating to me in a uh uh I think I
said on an interview or something I said
you know we're sending billions of
dollars to many other conflicts around
the world not just the Russia Ukraine
situation uh but then you look in you
know Jackson Mississippi they don't have
clean water or uh Flint Michigan and
some of these other things
um
forget this exact moment in time forget
these exact conflicts just from an Intel
perspective how does the United States
think about when to help abroad versus
when to help domestically and I know you
guys have done a lot of work on some
domestic stuff as well but like what
does that framework look like and does
it change and I think that's like a
really key piece to this is like does it
change with administrations does it
change with uh various threats or is
there a pretty rigid hey these people
are focused on domestic these people
focusing internationally
well there are different organizations
you're you're dealing with in different
objectives I I don't I don't even know
the calculus on on how the US government
decides to help uh domestically but yeah
it is it's a shame it's a shame that we
see so much going to Ukraine while there
are veterans who are still trying to get
access to the VA and they're still
homeless you know Americans and and kids
who are not eating in this country I'm
not saying those things are necessarily
the government's job I'm just saying
it's it's interesting where we send our
money yeah there's a lot of problems in
the world in general but also there's a
lot of problems here uh domestically as
well
um some of the I think when I first
started coming across some of your work
uh 2020 uh uh you guys seem to become
very popular in a lot of circles uh
because you were uh tracking a lot of
the domestic activities
um political extremism uh a lot of the
uh um everything from uh protests to
riots to violence to threats kind of
just it seemed like you were trying to
build the the board game right and
you're trying to understand it uh and I
think what I and many other people
appreciated uh who followed you on
Twitter and stuff like this is it seemed
like there was we are not on any one
side we are trying to understand what's
happening here and almost have kind of
taken a step to the sideline and we're
watching the field right and to talk a
little bit about uh kind of through 2020
into 2021 what you guys were seeing kind
of what was that like in terms of trying
to actually get that information and and
ensure accuracy I think to some degree
in a time where there's a lot of
movement and kind of things changing on
a day-to-day basis
this this goes back to 2016 and one of
the reasons why I started Ford Observer
is because there's a lot I mean there's
just a lot of institutional money a lot
of focus on tracking far-right groups
and they really gloss over far left
groups and I'm not talking about your
you know run-of-the-mill Bernie Bros
these there are a lot of Revel actual
revolutionaries out there and so you
know even when you look at the the
quote-unquote anti-fascist movement you
know they're they're they won't be happy
if if Trump's gone right it'll be on to
the next Domino onto the next thing
people who are not fascists and not I
don't even think Trump was a fascist
and why is that
because they're revolutionaries they
want to they want to topple the
capitalist system and in many cases
they're you know also various flavors of
anarchists and they want to talk they
want to live in a state-free society so
what hang on if you're the US government
here Al should you know how are you not
giving more uh you know more due
diligence to these groups because you
read their the zines and the pamphlets
and the Flyers and stuff they pass out
and you read their blogs and see what
they're posting on social media
um they they're not talking about hey
guys let's go organize a protest
um I mean they do that too they're I
mean they're sharing like uh Carlos
marigella and all these leftists
Insurgent literature and you know the uh
manuals about how these communist
insurgents and revolutionaries carried
out their own their own revolutions
abroad and so this is not just like a
run-of-the-mill protest group so so when
we look at that we can go to direct
sources I mean we just we go read what
they say we watch the videos do all
those things
when I hear you say that what I take
away from it is uh you got extremism on
the right you got extremism on the left
and maybe the common perspective or
shared uh uh dream
the US government does not look uh the
way it is does not have the power it has
all the stuff right where they
drastically diverges what happens next
kind of what what does that world look
like uh whether it is uh kind of more
right you know leaning in kind of all
things that generally get assigned to
that group versus a left-leaning world
that that is stateless or kind of less
of the US government is that fair that
there is commonality of like destruction
of the system but really the Divergence
is uh maybe on the tactics in which to
do it but then also on like what the
system looks like uh on the other side
of that event
yes I mean there are some commonalities
I would say the biggest Divergence and
especially in how the US government
looks at these groups is there are a lot
of people in institutions left-wing
institutions in the United States and I
would include the US government in there
as they they look at the extreme left
and they say uh yeah that's not a great
look but they're useful
and I I think I mean there's I can tell
that that's probably the number one
reason why this far left groups don't
get the same look as the far-right
groups and you know also too I mean the
right the right in general is just much
better armed the US government is not in
a position where they can allow those
groups to organize and coordinate
do you think that
um when you say they're useful what does
that mean
well I think audio ideologically they're
useful in you know try in 2016 you know
trying to beat back on trumpism trying
to you know beat back on you know it's
always amazing the the anti-fascist
groups antifa they they never go after
like the hardcore skinheads and big
biker gangs who will like literally kill
them you know they go after you know the
the more milk toast right-wing groups
you know out in the street but who's I
don't know who's the bigger fascist
maybe the the white what supremacist or
white nationalist skinhead biker gang or
the kids out in the street
so you think that it's almost like uh I
don't know
biological like human nature [ __ ] where
it's like who who's the who's the
[ __ ] Alpha on the street when you
know there's no police there's no
anything and so like pick on what is
perceived as the weaker group and so
that's where like the focus goes
I don't think it's necessarily well that
I mean you know you look at at those
groups and they are much weaker compared
to like you know a a white nationalist
biker gang like you know the one
percenter clubs or whatever
um I I they one of the things that the
these left-wing people chain is who
streets our streets whose streets our
streets yeah and so they you know these
groups see themselves as well we cannot
allow them to proselytize to talk about
their you know their issues and
grievances you can't allow them to hold
the demonstration on the street you have
to go out and counter it and you know
maybe it's the case that you know it's
not those biker ganks who are out there
demonstrating
um but yeah you know I think this is
really a case of
uh you know it the the younger
right-wing activist groups are out there
and they have to be countered because
they you cannot allow them to grow but
you know I'd even say a lot of those
groups I mean they're just they're like
milk toast right wing they're not was
that milk toast yeah you know they've
never heard that before I mean they're
like conservative plus you know they're
they just they a lot of the watered-down
version
yeah I don't even want to say they're
the watered down version I mean there
there is a fascist movement in this
country it's so small most of them are
you know tell me more about that because
I think and and you know already I can
see people are freaking out they're like
holy [ __ ] what are you guys talking
about whatever right but but I think
what's fascinating about your
perspective is your is you don't come at
this from what I can tell uh one side is
good the other side is bad right someone
how we're talking about Russia Ukraine
like look this shit's messy and there's
a lot of different groups and they're
all got their own [ __ ] angles and and
frankly some of the perception of what
those groups stand for may not actually
be what they stand for if you go and you
look at the source materials and and so
you all spend your time trying to figure
that out right which I appreciate
because it's uh frankly more educated
than most people here talk about it but
when you say
um let's maybe just go kind of group by
group you said there is a fascist
movement movement in the country what
does that look like how do you guys
evaluate how big it is how serious it is
what the threat is just kind of walk me
through that
well when when the mainstream talks
about fascist what they're really
talking about is those on the right who
want to use government in the same way
that that the left wing wants to use the
government okay okay the same way they
want to weaponize government against
which which is exactly what the demo I
mean I think so there's probably some
element of both Democrats and
Republicans doing this but you look at
conservatism and they say no that we we
don't need to use government power it's
a dangerous weapon you know it's a
cudgel we don't want to use it and then
you see Democrats and I'm not trying to
be partisan this is just my observation
and Democrats get in there and they do
weaponize it they weaponize the IRS
against the Tea Party they weaponize DHS
they weaponize all these groups like how
many just as an example how many murders
do you think are attributed to White
supremacists per year in the United
States just ballpark it
oh man
um
say less than a thousand maybe less than
200 something like that like I'm
assuming it's a small number yeah sure
yeah according even to the most liberal
sources like 30 about 30 a year okay so
the the domestic violent extremism is
about diminishing 30 mer now of course
there's there's other forms of murders
bad right yeah but but just murders in
general about 30 a year you know more
people will die due to gang crime in
Chicago in one month or in one year then
you get white supremacist murders in 10
years so you know again this is just
like misplaced priorities and I do
Wonder a lot why is the emphasis so why
is this so great an emphasis on a
movement that's so small okay do you
have a theory as to what that is
well uh
yeah yeah that sounds like yes
I yeah I so I I see I do see many
Democrats publicly issue violence but I
think they they enjoy seeing
people in in 2016 through 2020. I think
they they enjoyed seeing Trump
supporters get beaten and and get death
threats and you know have uh various you
know forms of a protest uh getting fired
economic dislocation like they really
wanted to punish Trump supporters and it
just so happened
that you have the these left-wing groups
do that and so I think it's a case of
yeah violence bad but but don't stop
so
when you point that out that is um what
I would call uh the the uh Pro right
critical view of the Left Right is kind
of the way to look at it if we then turn
and flip that the other way and we say
okay what is like the uh Pro left
critical of the Right View uh is you
said already hey there is this fascist
group it's small but but it exists are
there other things that you think uh
have some kind of uh um seriousness or
or accuracy to them from that uh angle
of critique
yeah I would even say like your your
average American you know fascist I has
nothing on 1930s ABS absolutely nothing
but I do think the moo it's small but it
is growing and I think they're trying to
be proactive
yeah the anti-factor trying to be
proactive and they say well one is one
too many because if they're if if you
let one go then there's going to be two
and if there's two then there's ten if
there's ten there's a thousand and
uh but I would just say on the other
hand if you look at the the common
gripes the the actual complaints among
these right-wing groups
it is because the the country is
changing so fast they're very
uncomfortable with the rate at which
society is changing and you know you
look at Biden even and you know he said
oh you know I'm I'm going to bring two
groups together and what did he do I
mean he turned around and just is very
very divisive and I look at the things
that the government is doing
so I'll give you an example right Biden
could come out and and he could say to
conservatives I understand your
complaints about border security and if
Biden
replaced Mallorca because he's obviously
not interested in doing it if Biden
replaced him with someone who could seal
up the Border as well as it was from
2016 to 2020. that would go a long way
in Bridging the Gap and turning down the
temperature on a lot of anti-government
uh extremism or protest or sentiment but
we don't see government doing that we
see government doing the option the
absolute opposite of that going after
border patrol agents who are trying to
secure the border and so I look at it as
a way it's like a self-licking ice cream
cone I mean you just get this thing
spinning and uh you know government does
does things to to make more people angry
more people anger they say okay well we
have to we have to organize and then you
have the other side saying well look
these people are organizing now and uh
the process could be stopped I think
uh but I don't think either side would
be happy with where we're going to go if
it doesn't stop are you familiar with uh
the Mike Glover situation have you seen
this somewhat yes okay um I I'm not but
I saw him Post online and um my takeaway
which hopefully you can uh correct me if
I'm wrong on this was uh he's an
organization uh very focused on Veterans
and in this stuff uh at some point uh
there was a very small number I think
single digit number of people uh who
kind of lost their way right it sounded
it sounded like frankly they got went
crazy and they started uh uh taking
their view of what the organization
should be to the extreme and again just
like classic radicalization extremism
like like all this stuff uh and we've
seen that like psychologists have
studied this for centuries right and
decades and understand that like you can
have a group that is net good and
majority of people are good and there's
radicalization and like that isn't
necessarily the entire group but still
it's a problem right
um and so what I think I understood from
what he was saying is like hey there was
these people and like once we identified
that this was it we kicked him out we
were super cooperative and like that's
not what we're about
and then it feels like uh he then said
hey but our organization has now been uh
identified as one of these extremism
groups and kind of all this stuff
and in that scenario again I I'm not an
expert on it
but it highlighted to me the complexity
of this where you could have a group and
a leadership team that says hey we want
to go do good things and and kind of
support of all these which I think most
Americans like hey we should take care
of veterans we should like do these
things
there's a radicalization within the
group which we see on both sides right
but but there's radicalization within
the group
the organization tries to do what they
perceive to be the right thing it seems
like most people from the outside are
like yeah that was the right thing was
to it was kind of separate yourself from
the radicalization uh but then you also
ask yourself like what should the
government do and like you get into this
like weird game where it's like it's
very unclear what is the right answer as
to how the various Market participants
in that scenario should act is that
one example of many on both sides of the
aisle that you see kind of as you guys
do your work in terms of like again you
said you can't label good and bad and
you know geopolitical conflict is it
possible to label good and bad in the
domestic issues as well
well yeah I mean you
and you're and you're free to tell me
that I'm an absolute idiot and got the
whole situation wrong no no Glover no no
you can I mean labeling good and bad is
easy it just depends on your I just want
to say you know let's consider the
alternative that both are bad
in in many instances yeah so which is
not a story that you hear in the
mainstream media many times right sure
good and bad is the divisive thing that
can allow you to have people pick sides
and argue and all this stuff but like
both are bad you know that seems a
little bit uh turning the temperature
down a little bit actually by saying no
both sides are bad yeah well yeah it's
really tough when yeah it's really tough
when the both sides are who are the
sides that are capable of stopping it
are both bad and don't want to stop
I would say
you know for the Glover thing you know
I'm not I don't know exactly but yeah I
think your your understanding is I think
it's probably accurate
um the the problem is if you go back to
the the radical parts of that group who
maybe misconstrued this they thought
American contingency was something that
it was not
um you know it's not a vehicle for for
violent revolution or anything like that
but I would go back and really try to
understand the the con the concerns and
what is driving the radicalism among
those people the first step in solving
the problems is understanding it
unfortunately there's just a lot of
journalists are lazy and they'll say oh
yeah my buddy over it whatever he said
oh this group is fascist so yeah okay
I'm gonna call this group fascists and
you actually go back and you look at
some of these groups and they're not
really a spaz you may not like what they
espouse but they're legitimately not
fascist groups and so
I you know I would try to understand the
problem and in many cases what the
federal government is doing like okay
the whole Epstein uh Maxwell thing right
okay why why do we not know I mean why
is the government not going after those
people but they will go after a PTA the
FBI will go uh conduct surveillance on a
PTA group because some parents are angry
at what their children are learning in
school you know so if we want to turn
down sounds crazy but like that is an
actual reality absolutely yeah
absolutely yeah and it's just like uh
there was some anti-abortion activists
like like seven-year-old people and this
one woman she she sat down in front of a
front door of an abortion clinic and so
that's a federal crime and now she was
arrested and I think 11 people are
actually being charged now by the
federal government for obstruction of
something some law that was passed in
the 90s and I'm not saying she will get
this but she's facing 10 years in
federal prison
um you know how how is she facing 10
years and someone who burnt down a
building in Minneapolis not how are they
going after thousands of hours of of
tape and man hours and millions
multi-millions of dollars to direct down
somebody who is standing outside the
capitol on January 6 2021 and they're
not going after the same people who
burnt down buildings and literally
murdered people during the summer of
2020. it's the misapplication of Justice
it's really selective application of
justice that makes people angry so and I
see I think on both sides the the belief
that uh the other side is uh not getting
enough attention in the whole thing but
one of the things that you're
highlighting here so let's take
um January 6th and let's take summer of
2020 uh Minneapolis I think is the one
that I personally remember watching and
being like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] just got
ratcheted up right and and uh my
recollection of the events which
somebody will correct me if I'm wrong uh
there was uh uh protest and it seemed
relatively peaceful and kind of all the
stuff during the day at least the the
coverage of it was uh this is no
different than protests that were
happening all over the country and in
many cities and then at one point I
don't know if I frankly just went and
ate dinner or something and came back or
what but all of a sudden it was like
there's a police station on fire and uh
that's when it was like oh [ __ ] this now
is a different level and and who knows
who did it why they did it like any of
this it was unclear at the moment it was
just like
that isn't the situation and then I
think there was a uh in Tennessee
somebody tried to set like a courtroom
on fire and it started to just kind of
spread us to like hey this got ratcheted
up so we take these two events
the left attacks the right on January 6
and says uh uh Insurrection and there's
the photos and generous committee all
that kind of stuff
the right attacks left and says yeah but
there is a police station on fire and
kind of all this stuff
when we look at these what you're
essentially arguing is like
they're taking different approaches they
have different views of the world but
both sides are actually unhappy in those
scenarios and they believe the system is
not working for them they believe that
the uh the government is not serving
what their need is
which is not the story that I hear
publicly or see in the media it's you
know one side's good one side's bad the
whole thing but like actually if you
kind of just everyone take a deep breath
for a second and say hey both of these
sides are saying this is not working for
them
what is the release valve what is what
is the like kind of escape hatch
or is there not one is it just literally
just keeps getting ratcheted up and you
have two sides that are just more and
more divisive and then we get you know
some sort of bad situation that you know
is even worse than things that we've
seen in the past or is there a release
valve where to your point you know is it
the president uh whoever the next
president is or the current one who can
kind of provide uh uh this Escape Route
is there other things that can happen
like what is that release valve because
it doesn't feel like that's obvious
today
this is I mean we are locked in a spiral
right now because you have these far
left groups they have they've been kind
of you know mostly dormant since uh
since you know probably February 2021 or
so
um we're probably in a position where if
uh if Republicans do end up taking the
house and the Senate I think a lot of
those groups will probably reignite
getting closer to 2024 that becomes I
mean it's it's a certainty they will
and so really the next two years I think
are going to be very difficult
um and the right will look at that and
say oh look they're they're organizing
again the Communists are back at it like
now we have to organize and the far left
will say Oh look The far right's
organizing now like we have to really
get on the ball and you know it's that
self-licking ice cream cone problem
that's that's what we're locked in the
best we can hope for I don't think this
is going to happen but the best we can
hope for is that in 2024 there is a a
candidate who wins outright with with
minimal accusations of voter fraud uh
maximum trust in the outcome that yes
this was a free and fair election the
problem is we have not had one of those
in some time and I think this is
probably the case where the longer you
go
without a legitimate all-around
legitimate Victor
uh the more likely it becomes that you
still want the best case scenario is
that yeah someone gets elected and
everyone accepts it I don't think that's
going to happen so this is interesting
because when you say it hasn't happened
in a long time
um
my mind immediately jumped whether good
or bad uh right or wrong uh Chad right
in Florida and like for those that are
too young to understand like literally
go watch documentaries or watch the news
segments or whatever like literally they
were arguing over like did the paper get
punched or not and like pretty [ __ ]
crazy stuff to determine who ultimately
became the president United States right
right
um and so like that is very different
than uh the accusations and kind of both
sides of the uh 2016 uh uh situation but
like that still was a a contentious
multi-day Affair that like people kind
of forgot about or were too young that
uh maybe paying attention now
Barack Obama doesn't seem like there was
uh as much contention maybe you disagree
um but that seems like maybe uh one
election where it was like okay he wins
transition from my recollection wasn't
anything that that necessarily sticks
out of of issue you get Trump who I
don't think most people said oh you know
the election uh um uh was rigged or
anything like that but it was uh
definitely uh once I was very happy once
I was not very happy and so kind of uh
in some way that's almost like what
politics have been for a long time but
it felt like it was ratcheted up for a
whole bunch of reasons
2020 happens now it's the accusations of
actually rigging and all the stuff
right now in Brazil right uh which I'm
not an expert I don't think you are
either
um there's an election and I've already
seen people saying it's real it's not
real like and it almost feels like okay
now there is a Playbook that has been
established that when an election occurs
we're gonna just see these accusations
over and over and over again that scares
the [ __ ] out of me yeah right because
that feels like uh
damn the United States was above this
right like to some degree like this is
what you see in in developing nations in
in areas where like
politician a politician and a warlord
and like maybe the warlord just says hey
now I'm the president yeah
what how do you evaluate this like how
do you think about it
yeah it's tough
so you know if we go back to 2016 and
and after that election you have I don't
know 25 30 I don't know the exact number
but somewhere around there maybe a third
maybe more of the country saying Trump's
illegitimate the Russians got him
elected okay and then 2020 you say well
you've got the the overnight hey it's
3am and all of a sudden you get this
massive
dump of votes for Biden in a few in a
handful of key States and it tips them
over the top and uh now you know third
of the I don't again I don't know the
exact numbers but let's just call it a
third of the country says Biden's
illegitimate
well you know I look at 2024 and I say
well we've seen some violence from the
right we've seen capability we've seen
the right organizing we've seen violence
from the left they've been organizing
um is 2024 going to be the trigger that
sets off increased violence
and you know that's one of my concerns
is you know you get into a situation
where like you have an Argentina
Argentina scenario like kind of a dirty
Civil War where one side or the other
gets elected and they say oh the left
are doing this or the writer doing this
like we have to go after them they're
terrorists they're domestic insurgents
they're all the things that you know
that conservatives have been called
Trump supporters have been called and
you know and then and there is some
legitimate organized political violence
not just not just opportunistic violence
but like Team Deathmatch you know like
Hey we're a group we're going to go out
and conduct political violence which is
the ABS you know really one of the worst
worst case scenarios you're saying that
uh that is a possibility or that's
happened in the United States I think
that is a possibility so far we've made
I think it's mainly been kind of ad hoc
opportunistic violence like mob violence
for instance is it bad I I almost call
that uh uh stupidity right like there's
people who
um mob mentality happens they're out
they're doing stuff whatever and like
opportunistically something a situation
equation shows itself and somebody is
either too emotional too stupid to
whatever and like something occurs and
all hell breaks loose right but what
you're talking about is I don't know uh
uh much more organized than that and
much more intentional like we are going
to go affect change in a way with
violence yeah effects based yep I think
that's that's the worst case scenario
that can if if the 2024 election the
contested election accusations is a
trigger for that type of violence and
yeah we've seen like proud boys and
antifa get into it and I I would not
call that organized political violence
um you know this is this would be more
of like uh you know a group of people
going out and saying hey this is it
we're going to kick off the Civil War
and and that's this is something that if
it were to get going
just very you know decentralized
distributed groups saying okay well
they're doing it over there I guess it's
our turn over here now
um you know that scares the [ __ ] out
it's bad I mean it could be very very
bad it's not it can be very very bad it
can be so bad that the government may
not in fact be able to stop it and this
the situation you would run into is the
government actually making matters worse
I'm not sure that that's something that
you can just let die out
but
um it's also a very tricky I mean you
saw in Iraq and Afghanistan too I mean
one slight misstep you know you're going
to make some other people angry and and
you you're going to trigger another
another round over here sons of Iraq
yeah exactly I I
um I've told the story before the people
uh I don't know if ever tried on the
podcast
um and again my memory over a decade ago
so uh uh uh we'll [ __ ] things up so
don't hold against me
um but basically the United States was
uh engaged in combat in Iraq uh we
pretty handily took the country uh from
The Invasion perspective and then we
went to nation building mode uh and we
had a hard time uh and it was pretty
obvious fairly early we're not built to
do this
um and uh the United States was
susceptible to kind of the Insurgent
attacks uh and one of the turning points
uh or at least in in kind of a momentum
shift was going to uh young military men
in Iraq and saying uh this is your
[ __ ] country right and like you need
to have national pride and you you need
to stand up because we can't do it right
and and in some way
um it's crazy to hear United States
military saying hey we can't do this
right uh but they essentially uh armed
trained and then helped to staff uh what
essentially checkpoints right I mean I
remember we'd go do night route
clearance and we'd drive by and you know
look we'd give them [ __ ] because they're
sleeping and stuff right but like they
were out there and uh and they had their
weapons and
um they knew they knew it better than we
did right talk about Intel like right
these you've been here for 18 20 25 30
years like you understand who who's a
good guy who's a bad guy who should be
in your town who should not be in your
town and it changed the battlefield now
people argue how effective was it how
long did it last whatever but like
that was a form of what we're talking
about where there was ultimately yes it
was a U.S led effort but there was a
group of Nationals in Iraq for military
age who basically got together and said
we got to put an end to some of the [ __ ]
I don't think the United States it's
very unclear to me that that would be a
good situation nor uh it would be
allowed I mean just like there's so much
different we are not in an active combat
zone right you know like we live in a
country that I like to think is uh is
safe and people can speak their mind and
do all these things you're talking about
a world that is very different than you
know the world maybe that I want to live
in and it appears that we live in at the
moment
without a trigger to head somewhere else
yeah you know the kind of the ironic
things yeah sons of Iraq was a it was
petraeus's answer to and and other
people uh their answer to Al Qaeda in
Iraq you know you had the whole
political party forming in ambar
Province you know before it became sons
of Iraq proper but that didn't stop the
killing you know they yeah they went out
and you know grabbed a bunch of Al Qaeda
in Iraq guys and shot him dead in the
street and called us hey by the way you
come pick this guy up like he's gone now
uh but yeah I mean it didn't it did that
guy on your playing cards yeah yeah
that's right yeah right for those that
don't know go uh uh the United States
literally had 52 deck uh playing cards
with faces of Iraqis on it which you
know tells you exactly what the mission
was yeah yeah and so you know that was
uh I mean that was a
roughly organic movement at least at the
very beginning the sahawa Iraq movement
and uh but yeah you know the the thing
was okay you have a bunch of these Sunni
Fighters and uh you know middle age or
military age males yeah let's let's form
up into a militia so they can they can
protect their
oh yeah so I yeah so let's let's form a
bunch of these middle-aged uh
military-aged males up and put them into
a militia and they can go protect their
country well it didn't stop ethnic
violence I mean it didn't it did it did
it in uh uh inflame it did it make it
worse or was it just kind of uh the
Baseline is the Baseline and the players
are different yeah in some areas yeah
because these were these were sunnis and
Malachi Shia was president and at the
same time you know Malachi was trying to
sideline suti sunnis in the Iraq Army
and so you know this and we see the same
thing in Afghanistan oh you go help this
tribe well guess what this tribe has
been an enemy of this other tribe for a
thousand years and now this other tribe
thinks you're against them and so
they're going to start attacking you now
I don't know that there is a way to win
but but you you bring up you know good
point sons of Iraq was meant to
stabilize Iraq and it it did it mostly
it did especially in ambar province
uh but but what you you know one of the
things you really did was enable
militias to go after she is
you know in some instances
this idea of a release valve
you mentioned uh 2024 whichever side
wins they win emphatically right it is
clear to everyone hey that is the winner
um and there's acceptance of that winner
when that occurs
and I'm saying when because I'm hoping
that happens
um
what is kind of the second and third
order effects do we is it possible to
wind back the clock kind of go go back
to pre
um all of the the pressure that's built
up and all of the the just I'm gonna
call it nonsense because frankly I I
think there's a lot of people in the
country who are just like look I don't
want to live in a world like this
um but is it possible to return or is
there now uh kind of this idea of like
you Advanced so far and like that's the
new Battleground that's kind of the new
boundary
I think the real problem is social
cohesion okay explain that
well I'm social cohesion I mean people
people getting along they have shared
values shared language shared culture
uh shared you know Outlook
and unfortunately you know you go back
and you read uh Sir John glub's fate of
Empires and he talks about Empires
follow a specific cycle and he says last
about 250 years you know roughly uh 10
generations and it starts with the
outbreak of an Empire you have a new
leader or a new idea and
um and it and it catches on like you win
a big victory over someone you take
their land and okay now you start your
Empire and you get into the age of
pioneers and they're you know they're
settling and and expanding the Empire
and then you have the age of Commerce
well guess what more commercial
interests you have the more military you
need to protect it and so you start
military expansion and then later on in
the cycle you get to the age of
intellect and the people who are living
then are so far removed from the initial
spark uh that's actually birthed that
Empire they're so far removed they don't
get it they don't share those values
anymore they don't share the same
Outlook and you know glove talks about
all the the all the factors at play and
you know he said the Assyrian Empire
lasted for about 247 years roughly
British Empire 250 years Pax Romana
lasted 270 years so we're all you know
according to him we're about in a 250
year Ballpark and one of the things that
happens at the end of Empire is you lose
social cohesion which is exactly what's
happening in the United States and at
first I said well this is a single
Source information let me go look and
there are other researchers someone
complete and I don't remember his name
and I probably couldn't even now
pronounce it if I could remember it but
he calculated up his own like 30 some
odd Empires and he found this like 260
270 years which is very darn close to
gloves 250 years so I actually think
there's quite a bit of of the math is
right at least yeah what's interesting
is uh there's a number of generations
there right and uh um one of the things
that uh in the investment world or in
the finance world uh there's um uh
paraphrase of it but uh basically you
know the first generation makes the
money second generation does a pretty
good job of holding on to it by the
third generation is gone right you know
and then and uh this is obviously
expanded into 250 you know year range
but like sure damn sounds pretty similar
right of uh kind of there's people who
create a a Empire or a a country
um there's people who kind of take care
of it and then there's people who [ __ ]
it up essentially right um and you know
I think we hope that doesn't happen uh
but let's say that let's play this out
right and say okay that's where we're
headed
what do you do you just Hey where's the
next Empire going to be built and let me
go you know where it's prosperous and
safe and kind of on the rise and it's
the equivalent of uh somebody who's
worked at a big tech company for you
know 10 years saying [ __ ] I'm going
to a startup that's the next great tech
company uh or do you stay and try to
change it like what what happens yeah
so Peter turkson has a he's a or was a
professor and he's studied the rise and
fall of states and one of the things he
says is I if I recall correctly
and two things end up happening is is a
civilization or an Empire is either
conquered by a neighboring Empire
or it falls from within and and it's
brought down internally and it is at
some point replaced by something else so
you know you look at the British Empire
I mean the United Kingdom Britain still
exists as a country it's just no longer
an Empire and maybe this is what happens
to the United States is I think I think
there are probably several things that
that could happen but you know maybe
it's just the United States doesn't go
away it doesn't cease to exist like we
just don't have a carrier strike group
station in Japan anymore
and and and the dollar is no longer the
world Reserve currency and you know in
terms of what can you do you have to get
to a state that I think is fiscally
responsible
and a state with a leadership that is
going to look out for for its its
residents a state that has good industry
you produce something you make something
you export something of value and I
think that's probably the best place you
can be in
because the the political establishment
you have at the governor and the state
legislature May well be the one that you
keep that becomes your new government
I'm just saying you know following into
logical conclusions here uh get you got
to get to a good State now yeah if you
think that's going to happen
learn so much about this stuff like what
you guys do at uh the business you
essentially look around the world and
you try to come up with Intel quality or
what I call like military quality Intel
uh and my
oh yeah I don't know the military
yeah that's a very low bar all right
explain uh my joke that many people may
have missed their military grade Intel
yeah uh explained well you know it's
just like I had a meeting with someone
the other day and I was explaining what
they do and oh you're like your military
grade so like anything military grade is
is made by the lowest bidder it is not
the quality you think it is so yeah
military great and plus there's the joke
you know about yeah whatever the joke is
about in my there's many of them yeah
the military folks will get that one um
but you guys obviously you take a lot of
the stuff that you uh learned military
and implemented their uh contractor work
now you're doing it in the private
sector uh but the folks who are
consuming this are uh everyone from
who's just interested in events around
the world trying to learn and educate
themselves to professionals who are
making uh decisions whether they're
corporations investment firms whatever
how do you uh kind of like go through
the event so maybe a great way to think
about this is like you wake up in the
morning when you you check are you
checking the news are you checking
internal proprietary dashboards or you
just jumping on Twitter like the rest of
us where you're taking a [ __ ] and you're
like you know what are people tweeting
about what what is the kind of the first
couple things that you do in the morning
from a a professional kind of Intel
standpoint yeah you know we we spend a
lot of money on on access to information
various databases and so yeah you know I
wake up I'm I'm sitting on my computer 5
30 most most mornings really checking
what happened overnight making sure
China hasn't you know nuke Taiwan or
whatever uh you know
just looking at what really what
happened overnight checking you know
kind of the first thing domestically off
the press is what's what's domestic
media reporting and um you know I have
my feed set up and keywords and topics
that I'm looking at and so you know yeah
I mean from from the get-go we just we
catch up on what happened overnight and
then we kind of add it to to our
expectations and you know a lot like
Financial people do you know you wake up
and you check Asian markets
Twitter how important is it for uh for
the Intel world
well for
the Intel world is I mean it's very
important you are I mean they're citizen
journalists they're apparent you know
basically I mean they can if something's
happening in in Japan or in Egypt a lot
of the times yeah you might learn about
it first on Twitter but you know and and
you know you even seen you know print
media and other people's site Twitter
sources like oh we saw this on Twitter
and so my favorite is when it's like a
pseudonymous account and they're like
[ __ ] up they don't know who it is they
just say like you know the cat or
whatever yeah yeah yeah so yeah Twitter
makes you know Twitter is in a lot of
cases is the first place where you'll
find this and and I would say even more
importantly that than that Twitter's
where you'll find alternative Source
sources of information and even if it's
you know and it's not the The
journalistic Narrative or the The
state-backed Narrative that you're
reading
and in some newspaper somewhere you know
it's someone that said oh yeah I was
there this is this is actually what
happened or this is my perspective for
here's the non-state sanctioned version
of what happened we've talked a lot
about geopolitics about domestic issues
kind of uh um you know social all these
different things uh it's not all you all
do right um so uh there's things like
fuel shortages and and other components
talk a little bit about that part of the
work and like why is that important and
kind of what are the decisions people
are making what's actually able to kind
of get their hands on this type of
reporting
so you know we I mean we exist to
produce early warning
a lot you know a lot of
a lot of times
the information is there and just only a
few people are have put it together a
hedge fund has put it together and
they're acting on it they're not telling
anybody because they want the advantage
so we try to act as like kind of a hedge
fund with with uh the quality of
information that that we can source and
then you know we draw logical
conclusions and really our goal is to do
that before it hits the news right I
mean you can read it in our report I
mean and this is it happens very
frequently you read in our report that
goes out every morning at 8 A.M central
time and you hear about it on the news a
day or two from now and so
our whole goal is to say hey this is
happening or this is going to happen or
this there's a good there's a good
chance this will happen over the next X
number of days and then yeah people can
act on it and they can make decisions
based off of that I mean really that's
what any good intelligence does
I'm fascinated by the private
privatization of various things in the
defense industry
um I think the probably the most famous
initial one was uh Blackwater and kind
of the contractors and and all of that
uh you do have examples on the
technology side and kind of a aspiration
to be the next great Prime in a company
like Andrew and a lot of the great work
that they're doing there
um is it possible to privatize the Intel
work and and uh is there a world where
uh the private sources end up uh maybe
not being in competition with the
military sources but but uh private
sources are relied on by military
leaders
absolutely look at maxar Technologies
and what they're doing right now in
Ukraine you know it's a private company
explain a little bit more about that
yeah I mean Macs are I mean they take
satellite imagery so their imagery
intelligence firm and
you know they're providing that to the
Ukrainian government you have the
Ukrainian mod making decisions based off
of of those satellites so yes we are
probably getting I mean just like black
water and the other places where
military action's been outsourced
that probably is the future of
intelligence uh there's a lot of in you
know in the in the military and the
government there's a lot of
institutional inertia and bureaucracy
and some of those things will have some
of those State sanctioned things will
probably have to continue to be carried
out by military or or civilian groups
but the use of contractors is
proliferated even for intelligence
gathering and that probably is the
future
um contractors for intelligence
gathering net positive net negative what
would have you was kind of your
evaluation of it so far
foreign
I spent my last tour to Afghanistan was
18 months I was doing uh roughly a
similar job that I would have done as as
a sergeant as an E5
um but I was getting paid a lot more to
do it I also didn't have
um I mean there's no forming morning for
formation and you know I don't have I
don't have you know a section Sergeant
or NCO you know double you know double
checking up on me and so
um
you know I think there's less kind of
less red red tape as a contractor that's
why I really enjoyed being a contractor
it's like wake up go do your job and and
just do it to the best of your ability
now not everyone did that but
um I think
a lot of the it's tough to say I just
they threw so much money at getting
contractors and I think a lot of that
money was wasted I would say net
positive because you um
you you get people who have experience
who want to be over there doing the job
just not in the military anymore because
there's just so much BS in the military
it um if I remember the numbers
correctly uh
if you were
combat engineer infantryman Etc in 2019
in Iraq uh with Hazard pay and kind of
all the different you know uh ancillary
payments I think he probably made I
don't know probably somewhere 70 80k
something like that 65 70. whatever the
number was it was below the 87 000
threshold that uh basically uh you
weren't taxed
um and I remember on the way out of Iraq
we went to Kuwait for two weeks
um or ten days whatever it was
and uh especially like a job fair right
uh set up there and there's all the
Contracting companies and it was like
listen if you turn your ass right back
you know you go home but like just go
right back to the country do exactly
what you were just doing sometimes even
a less dangerous job uh we'll pay you 90
000 for a six month contract if you
don't go home in those six months we'll
pay you 10K so it's 100K total you stay
for a year and don't go home it's 200k
right there's a lot of guys who's like
well [ __ ] I was just willing to do it
for way less money writing a lot more
bureaucracy and usually I was actually
putting more danger right why would I
not go back and and it always so you
know it's just like look what is the
value right if you think from business
mindset like what is the value of the
person in that country uh uh doing
something private sector had a lot more
value assigned to it than the uh kind of
Defense industry um or the military and
so it's just it's fascinating how uh you
can use money and what they're willing
to pay as a proxy for a lot of other
things yeah
unfortunately you know I think a lot of
that's probably ways Fraud and Abuse you
know
um but you know going to Big defense
contractors and you know we yeah you're
getting paid 200k what are they getting
paid yeah they're making weight so
yeah so I you know I'm just saying you
know I'm speaking from my my position
and my role what I was doing as a
contractor in Afghanistan uh however
um yeah it's it's a different time you
and I both learned a lot since we
enlisted and uh
you know I when I enlisted I was super
gung-ho and I get over there and I start
realizing like
this is not this is not what the average
you know flag wave in you know American
thinks it is which is you know very
unfortunate but you know to your point
yeah Contracting you get a lot higher
tier
um and you're not just taking volunteers
off the street you know it's like if you
come to work for our company you know a
company like black water some of the
other kind of top tier firms like you
you're gonna be worth your salt we're
not just going to hire anybody just
because they show up and fill out an
application
um
where's [ __ ] nasty business man right
it's a money maker yeah it was a
business but it's also just a nasty
situation where I think um uh one of the
things that has really bothered me
frankly is uh uh there's been a lot of
critiques of the Navy SEAL training
right and um I've actually never said a
story before but uh uh on the way to
Iraq uh we went to uh Fort Polk in
Louisiana uh about the uh absolute
shittiest place in the world because the
middle of the summer in the [ __ ]
insects and Mesquite I just it was
horrible right I hated it uh and I
remember uh we were doing these uh
training exercises
in preparation and uh on one of them uh
basically they were like are y'all gonna
go up here and you're gonna pull
security all right whatever go up there
pull security uh I was around like a
fake Village that they had built or
whatever and next thing I know I see
some dudes who just look cool
come out of the woods right and they're
[ __ ] doing their thing whatever and
and uh they're pretty quick and then it
was all right let's get out of here
we go back to where we're staying and
you know it's a bunch of guys here so
what the [ __ ] was that right so they
started asking around whatever it was
Navy Seals uh who supposedly uh they did
an exercise where they dropped off in
the ocean they swim they gotta [ __ ]
you know navigate their way or whatever
and that was kind of the conclusion of
it and so uh whatever I'm fine
were there and uh and these dudes are
staying in a uh in a Barracks that is
you know within eyesight
I'm [ __ ] exhausted so is every other
guy I'm with they're talking about what
are they gonna go eat whatever and we
see these seals and they're now working
out
these dudes are pulling tires and do I
mean just a whole thing like literally
out of a movie right right and I
remember sitting there staring at him
just being like I'm so glad those
[ __ ] are on our side
yeah like and that was the only
experience I had seeing the training and
like all the stuff and everything
but there's not very many people who
would have done that because my
understanding of what they had just done
was grueling already and then they still
hey I gotta get my workout in
and it feels like there's a disconnect
between the public conversation and then
when you see the reality and it's like
by the way some of those guys just do
the math like they didn't come home
right they they they even though all the
preparation still wasn't enough and so I
think that uh to your point about social
cohesion there's also like an education
and for an information standpoint the
more people can understand about some of
the stuff they realize
it's not necessarily good and bad it's
not necessarily you know clean cut hey I
want this streamed on National
Television or written in the New York
Times
because it's nasty
yeah yeah it's very unfortunate that
um I think there is
I'm going to tread lightly here because
I'm I'm not one of those dudes you know
obviously yeah but yeah you know I think
there is uh like when that when that
seal uh murdered one of the Green Berets
and uh I forget where where it was
um you know there's a lot of I think
there are things that that happen that
you know people call it toxic and and uh
you know just from reading the news you
you can get that
but those you know those guys I think
most of them are are like top tier
quality the best dudes you could
possibly want on your team and it's very
and again I don't have a dog in this
fight but
um unfortunately when you see the
political politicization of training
like non
um non-soft dudes making decisions for
how those guys are going to go through
their own Pipeline and go through their
own selection progress process like
don't mess with that let them run that
[ __ ] because they've got to deploy with
those people right they have to choose
who they want you know to join their
Brotherhood and so I think that's a
travesty what's happening right now is
people is or civilians people who really
are in no
probably have no business making those
types of decisions making those types of
decisions saying well we're going to cut
this this phase and we're going to allow
this to happen over here and is what he
optimizing for right like you know look
I meet a lot of Founders a lot of people
who want to work at various companies I
even talk to you know other investors
whatever I was like to ask what do you
optimizing for and some people what the
optimize before today may not be what it
is tomorrow or whatever
I think most of those processes they're
not perfect they'd be first to say that
most of the training processes most of
the selection processes Etc is they are
optimizing for the best absolute War
Fighters we can put on the battlefield
so we can be successful right and that's
how they were designed and that's how
they've been run and again they [ __ ] up
they make mistakes whatever they go too
far what all that stuff is true
but that is the what they're optimizing
for
it does seem to your point there's a lot
of people now who you know they have
interest whether it's intellectual
interest or or some other interest that
they're trying to figure out how they
can you know uh kind of meddle in this
that's not what they're optimizing for
optimizing for other things and again
maybe they're right maybe they're not
whatever but
that is a shift in in the Target right
that's the shift in what we're
optimizing for and like we should be
aware of that we should understand that
the goal is now shifting and we should
have a conversation around is that a
better goal to go after or actually are
we losing kind of sight of what these
people are going to have to go do and I
don't have the answers right I don't
think you claim to have the answers
either but you can see it happen and
it's kind of crazy to watch in real time
yeah I'm afraid this is maybe one of
those you know Empire indicators
where you know we're no longer
optimizing for lethality you know like
the the Mattis School of should we do
this with the military does it help us
kill more people faster if it does yeah
let's look at it if it doesn't then no
let's not do that and yeah just you know
the things you've canceled canceled yeah
I know yeah right the military killing
people like that is that is not good
right well you know you just the Marine
you know the Marines have that new ad
campaign out now right and it's not the
the pink haired you know person joining
the Marine Corps it's like Marines going
out and conducting operations and
killing people you know and I mean not
literally in in the ad but that's a very
that's a very important shift from what
we saw just a few years ago where you
know it's like a software a softer
gentler Marine Corps the the uh the
pendulum swings I think in both
directions as we've seen right
um and it does feel uh that it has swung
um but I also think there's recruiting
issues that they're having like there's
a whole bunch of stuff that goes into it
um I'll leave you with this because I
think you'll appreciate it uh
um a friend of mine was saying you know
what do you think about all the the
Russia Ukraine stuff or whatever and uh
I just said to myself I said I wonder
yeah let me go Google this and I went I
Googled something I came back to him I
said hey man there's a lot of people
advocated for world war three military's
paying 50 000 signing bonus for somebody
to sign up if they're so interested in
it right yeah they pay they pay you to
sign up right I don't see a line out the
door they're paying 50k because they
can't get a lot of people to sign up and
so I think that you know again I just
like looking at the market and if
they're having to pay these huge signing
bonuses it means that they can't get
enough people to sign up can't get
enough people to sign up but there's a
hell of a lot of people on Twitter
talking about you know I think in the
last four years four or five years
pretty sure that World War III has
trended on Twitter at least three times
it was the Iran situation the North
Korea situation and then the Ukraine
situation
so that's just a crazy world right and
again maybe that's just what's always
happened and now it's just on social
media or whatever but
they're paying that much and there's a
lot of people talking about it it just
seems like there's a disconnect
yeah
there's a very big disconnect and I'm
afraid that
that politicians are going to want to
fight the next World War which may be a
World War and their like Empire indicate
Empire ending implications if we lose
let's hope that doesn't happen yeah
where uh where can we send people to
find you on the internet uh or sign up
for uh for all the great work you guys
do yeah well thanks yeah I appreciate
the opportunity it's been a great
discussion you can I have our website
you can find us at forward observer.com
and uh we do a daily YouTube live stream
for about 15 minutes every morning talk
about global issues that's just the
forward Observer Channel over on YouTube
and uh I'm on Twitter and Instagram and
a bunch of other places under Gray Zone
warlord it's gray with an a
Gray Zone warlord what a great name all
right thank you so much I appreciate it
we definitely will do this again all
right yeah thank you